today we'll be speaking with
Charlottesville unite the right speaker
and embattled Washington State College
Republican President James alte + joshie
asthma Erin Bandler and thank goodness
Amanda Preston jacquimo joined the panel
of deplorable to discuss Kim jong-un
backing down
Iceland's Down syndrome genocide and the
most likes tweet in history I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
we're also going to talk if we have time
I should have mentioned why everybody
seems to be attacking Lincoln these days
there was some graffiti on the Lincoln
Memorial last night so we'll be talking
about that a little bit later so for our
guests today we're lucky to have James
Allsop we actually booked him before any
of this craziness happened over the
weekend between the neo-nazis and anti
feh in Charlottesville and we figured he
was there and in the spirit of open
discourse and debate we would bring him
on to tell us what he saw and describe
the event to us
James do we have you yes I'm here and
thank you for having me your name thank
you for coming great yeah of course ya
know Charlottesville was insane I think
that it was one of those situations
where going into it nobody really knew
exactly what to expect people had
different preconceived notions about
what might happen what they might see
there but once we got there on the
ground everything all of the plan kind
of went out the window well then I want
to talk to you that because you know I
also was a college Republican president
I remember I was involved in right wing
activism back when I was when I when I
was a pretty young thing such as you are
and my question about this unite the
right event is that it's called unite
the right it was organized by a number
of people but there weren't any
mainstream conservatives there there
were no representatives from the
mainstream of the conservative movement
there were no Republican politicians
that could be talked about there weren't
even alt light people like Serna vich
Gavin McGinnis turned it down based
stick man one of my favorite characters
from the internet they all turned it
down so the only people that I see there
are neo Nazis neo Confederates white
nationalists like Richard Spencer white
identity advocates like like identity
Europa why my question my
straightforward question to you is why
would you go what were you thinking
going well I was actually going to
deliver a speech about nationalism as a
concept not you know ethnic nationalism
about nationalism I was going to speak
about how nationalism is not a hateful
philosophy but it's a philosophy that is
based around love of you know your
country and your fellow countrymen and I
don't think it's quite fair to say that
the only people there were neo not
you know I was on the ground there and I
think there were others I think there
were white nationalists I think there
was Richard Spencer with the leader of
it I think there were neo Confederates I
think there were there were people I
sure like they forget his name the man
who organized it who said screw Lincoln
I'm a Southern Man I think there was a
lot of southern pride there but there
were a lot of neo Confederates and I
agree with you I don't think it's fair
to call them all Nazis but there were
swastika flags there and what's worse a
bet than that I didn't see anybody from
the other side any other people from the
right wing so when I see unites the
right I think it couldn't even unite the
alt-right it couldn't even bring the alt
light guys around and then my question
to you is knowing that even I understand
you wanna give a speech about
nationalism knowing the optics of that
knowing that you're known by the friends
that you keep why appear with Richard
Spencer and the KKK well I don't think
anybody knew the KKK was going to be
there I certainly didn't when I went
there and to be fair I don't think the
KKK really was there I mean we're seeing
this in the media right that the fake
news media is trying to make this out to
be some kind of KKK event but there were
no hood you know that the pictures they
were showing were four months ago that's
all the fake news narrow you would say
that was like the Richard Spencer is a
white nationalist and you would say he
was involved in leading this event sure
so I guess my question then is why would
you allow yourself to be associated with
somebody like Richard Spencer I don't
have to agree with everyone at Adam
glint right by appearing at an event I'm
not in no way co-signing the opinions of
everyone else who's there of course I
think but did you agree with anyone at
that event is I understand if they get
some they have some kook's
and then they have other points of view
and it's a free speech event and it's a
unite the right I understand that that
would be a different thing but did you
agree with it with any of these people
there
it depends what topic you're talking
about I mean on something like like
economics for example Spencer and I have
very different philosophies about a lot
of that story and by the way we would
have heard what all of these opinions
are we would have heard all these
different opinions and it could have an
accurate representation and understand
what these people actually believed in
if the event had been allowed to
continue I agree there clearly the
police did very little clearly an Tifa
were bullying everybody all around
you know it's in the in the fake news
media but occasionally they get
something right this event has been
called unite the white do you do you
think that there was a white identity
that was the major component of this
event I can't speak for everyone else
who was there I know that I was going to
speak about national ago do you think
the event was primarily a white identity
event I understand you were there for
that I'm not I'm not asking about your
motives I'm just asking if you think
that was what the event was I think that
may have been an aspect of it sure sure
I mean but at the same time you know we
have these events across the country we
have black lives matter events we have
La Raza on hundreds of college campuses
black and Hispanic identity is
completely obscene as completely okay by
course into the mainstream media and at
left so but do you think those are okay
do you think that lives matter in La
Raza and all those other identity ethnic
identity groups are all right and if you
don't think so as I don't I don't so
then why is it any better when we do it
when white people do I don't condone
violence yeah no I don't condone by but
I'm not talking about violence I'm
talking about I'm talking about this
identity mob organizer thing note that
now we're seeing replicated in some ways
on the old right sure but I think it's
fair to say you can differentiate
between black identity movements like
the hotep movement for example and black
lives matter so I guess black lives
matter wasn't a great example
I completely you know I think that the
violence perpetrated by people like
black white black lives matter or La
Raza in California that's a despicable
but I don't necessarily think there's
there's something wrong with you know
these identity movements because there
is a you know one of the unfortunate
truth when you look at societies that
have a lot of political stratification
like we do is that people will often
align along racial lines I'm not saying
that's good or bad I'm not saying that
that's the point you think we what you
think we have to admit it and we have to
accept it and are you saying that the
right in this country basically has to
appeal to white identity if it's going
to have a future I'm saying well I
wouldn't say it like that but I think
what you're seeing is if you look at the
data from Pew Research you're seeing
that the Republican Party is becoming
more and more made up of white people
and you're saying that that actually
minorities african-americans and
Hispanics are becoming further left
you're also seeing why Tamara
to become further right so and that
trend has been happening since the 70s
and as that trend continues I think we
will see some you'll continue to see
political realignment in that way I
think it depends I grant you some of
that I think it depends a little bit on
how you define left and right from the
70s through the 80s and 90s and 2000's
but I'm a little confused because the
alt-right has you know embrace I think
it basically defined itself as you are
defining it leaning in toward white
identity appealing to white demographics
and yet they all read is very new
movement as the political movements only
about a year old in public and during
Barack Obama's presidency we did not see
the Tea Party and other grassroots
movements appealing to white
demographics and yet we took over the
whole country we won so much we almost
got sick and tired of winning
we took a thousand seats in state
legislatures we got 24 at governorships
out of 32 Republican state legislatures
we took the Congress the Senate and the
presidency it looks like we did pretty
well without explicitly appealing to
white identity tell me I'm wrong
and we got nothing and we got nothing
done I mean Obamacare still in place we
have you know no new protections on
trade we didn't build the wall
Republicans guns but Republicans are
great at getting in power but they're
only getting things done when they get
in power but I exact a little confusing
cumulatively now it seems to me that
you're you're saying that as an
electoral strategy in order to win
elections we need to appeal to white
demographics but that doesn't seem true
from the last eight years but and then
you'll say the trouble is we get elected
we don't do it I totally grant you that
I absolutely grant you that the
Republicans in Congress have been
squishy and basically useless but they
seem to be different questions right how
do we win elections what do we appeal to
and how do we operate once we're in
office I think we can't be purely
introspective when we talk about this
question I think we also have to look at
the Democratic Party and the Democrats
have been going down this road where
they're employing a lot of anti white
rhetoric and they're aligning themselves
with people who are very very anti
whites with anti white messaging and
look you know for young white college
guys like myself who see a lot of that
messaging young male going on we're told
about white privilege and how white men
are responsible for everything the the
reaction for some people is to fold and
say yes you're right I'm evil because
I'm white but for a lot of people it's
to reject that narrative entirely and
say look you know that
right right throughout things yeah I
totally understand it seems to me that
for a lot of people your age a little
bit younger even even as old as I am
there we were told we were brought up in
this milieu of feminism and being told
that straight men are bad and white men
are bad and this that and the other
thing my concern is that seems to have
provoked a reactionary response that is
feeding the worst elements of the
identity politics that drove us crazy in
the first place do you have any thoughts
on that yeah no I can understand that
but I think we also have to look at this
as a defensive measure right there there
is a perceived attack and you know
whether this is entirely legitimate or
not there is a perceived attack on on
white people in this country it's coming
from the media it's coming from govern
it government is coming through the
education system with affirmative action
and there's a lot to be said for that if
they're the only arrears silicon sure
absolutely Silicon Valley puts out these
numbers and these diversity reports
every year it's you know the diversity
reports which are essentially they're
bragging about how many fewer white
people they hired and you know look I
don't think anybody should should be
subjected to that I say and I would say
that for any race I don't think any race
should should have to be you know
subjected to that kind of thing no one
and at the same time go ahead I'm sorry
go ahead
okay okay I'll finish quickly I was
going to say that every year you know
Republican politicians and Democrat
politicians consistently agree on
bringing in more h-1b visa applicants
this has the effect of driving down
wages for American labor that's really
what I'm concerned mostly about is an
America first policy when it comes to
our trade and our immigration and
reducing trade and immigration I agree
entirely which brings me back to my
first question believe it or not there
are other groups that have opposed
immigration and have advocated for lower
legal and illegal immigration who have
advocated for trade protective trade
tariffs since the since the nineties to
differing degrees of affect obviously
the Bush administration did not take
immigration enforcement terribly
seriously tried to push amnesty and and
so but that is the understatement of the
year don't you think there are other
groups that you can align yourselves
with it aren't as those who showed up in
Charlottesville
aren't explicitly white identity white
nationalist like Richard Spencer I'll
let you answer and then there's there is
something I'd like you to respond to
that I was perusing on your YouTube
channel
yeah no certainly and I consider myself
to be a paler conservative look I got
into politics back in 2012 with Ron Paul
so I'm coming at policy from it we all
are especially all when we were all
young evenly yeah we're all naive and
thinking about you know winning talk--i
strategies and stuff back in 2012 though
it was a good time but so I come at it
from a libertarian perspective with a
lot of this stuff and so I I look when I
when I look at politicians at people
like Paul Nayland who are excellent
representations of what I believe
America first policy should be I like
people like Steve King is another
fantastic example of someone who is
putting you know these workers first
actually did an interview with Paul
Nalin on my youtube channel where we
talked about a lot of the stuff we
talked about how the unit party the
Republicans and the Democrats are both
kind of screwing the American worker and
making things worse
for everyday Americans this is you know
just to get that I don't want to drive a
Ron Paul too quickly this is one of the
reasons why I'm interested in your
videos and I remember you know when I
was I was joking that it's 17 every kid
every young kid on the right resigned
ran and his convinced he knows
everything for about six months and then
he kind of floats away from it usually
move away from libertarianism what have
you and my worry with a lot of young
people and with you as well James I
worry that people are getting famous too
young and they're espousing his views
too young views that might change in
views that might be nuanced and I think
you're playing with bad juju with these
all right guys and to give an example I
will we have a clip of Richard Spencer
from your channel from a speech he gave
at the Lincoln Memorial
that's clip two zero zero one deal is
fighting for freedom
we are fighting for the constitution we
are fighting to the prank of foreign or
otherwise up against the five years
activity here fundamentally fighting and
our allies we are fundamentally fighting
for something that is bigger than
ourselves we are fighting to be parts of
a family together we are fighting to be
strong again to be beautiful again we
are fighting to be powerful again and a
sea of weakness and hopelessness that is
our battle I think he's absolutely
honest and absolutely right in
describing what he's doing this this
quest for meaning they're trying they
don't really care about the Constitution
that you know there's that meme but my
Constitution my Constitution doesn't
pretend anything if you don't have
voting demographics so it is how it how
it goes online the the question here I
wonder is what is that meaning what is
that meaning that the alright is trying
to embrace it seems to me it's just the
white race its color your skin and
communities that have historically lived
near each other am I wrong well I think
you'd have to ask which would Spencer
that question I I can't defend or or and
I don't have any interest in defending
everything Richards ever said you know
look rich I only asked you because it
was on your channel I only asked you
because I know you were at the event and
if you have in it you know you care
you've spent more time with these guys
than I had I think what they would say
is that they are fighting to - they're
fighting to I guess it rum continued the
flame of Western civilization right you
know people throughout Western
civilization throughout history have
built great things built great empires
done great things
you know the foundations of modern
philosophy and art and music all of this
comes out of a really you know mostly
Western Europe of core and they're
fighting to continue that that cultural
tradition and I don't see anything wrong
with that I agree and what I realized
and then this is my essential question
on that because I think that's exactly
right
I would I am an evangelist for Western
culture it's obviously the greatest
civilization the history of man
obviously providentially guided what is
Western coal
because my I highly suspect that most of
these people know very little about
Western culture what is it what is what
is the West what is Western culture well
I would actually argue that that one of
the greatest manifestations of Western
culture and values er the United States
founding documents it is this idea that
we can have a society that guarantees
freedom and liberties to people but also
inspires you to work towards bettering
yourself you know you're ultimately
responsible for yourself and the if you
think back in 1700 then late seventeen
hundreds we were a country and we were
founded as a country with a very very
small State for a reason but we were
also a country with very large you know
church groups right and communities
voluntary communities voluntary
Association we were founded as a country
that would be free from the trappings of
European royalty I guess you could say
very religious about all of Europe is
running away from Christianity of course
absolutely and and equalitarian by the
way around are created equal and are
endowed by the creator with unalienable
rights to life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness which would traditionally
be read and if you look at the seventeen
if you look at the 1790 Naturalization
Act it's very interesting because they
actually make it a required provision
where people who emigrate from Europe
renounce all of their former titles you
know you were a lord or or some kind of
you know royalty in Europe you actually
had to give that up and to to become an
American citizen you had to you know
accept that kind of that kind of you
know abandonment of the former hierarchy
right I think that right the American
values we were founded on are actually
one of the greatest manifestations of
Western civilization I agree and now my
so my question for all of these guys who
have a stated goal which is exactly the
same as my stated goal which is to
promote Western culture and and defend
Western culture but as we just said the
the Western culture it was expressed in
these founding documents in the the
notion that we are endowed by our
Creator with unalienable rights all of
these guys were Christian basically the
West it seems to me as a combination of
Athens in Jerusalem that spread
throughout Europe for two thousand years
ago seemed in the United States and and
elsewhere but Christianity is the
central factor right cult culture comes
from cult it's what we
so are these guys Christian are you
Christian yeah I was raised Christian
right I consider myself to be very
culturally Christian you mean by that
before we go yeah okay I'm sorry
continue yeah no no I honor that yes no
I believe that the Ten Commandment Kent
Ten Commandments and the biblical
teachings are a fantastic foundation and
should be the bedrock of Western
civilization and culture the Ten
Commandments and and the ideas expressed
in the Bible should really be the
guiding light for how we treat each
other and how we you know manage our
day-to-day dealings
you sound mostly Irish into me but where
so where do you disagree with them well
it's not that I disagree it's just that
I I don't participate in organized
religion to the extent where I would be
comfortable calling myself you know
Christian you believe in Jesus in that
degree sure I think everybody does don't
think you believe that Jesus is the only
begotten Son of God who came down to
save all of mankind and was killed and
then on the third day was literally
resurrected to redeem man you know I'm
not certain again I'm not I'm not up on
my Christian theology but I do believe
in these teachings and and I think that
it is absolutely imperative that we we
have respect for the Christian tradition
yeah yeah I see your point the reason I
want to interject a little bit here is I
think there are two issues with what
you've said I think the phrase
culturally Christian I've heard Richard
Spencer describe himself that way too
I think it is nonsense I think it is
etymologically not impossible I think
it's semantic nonsense because the word
culture comes from cult right it's what
we worship so to say one is culturally
Christian would appear to me to say we
believe in Christ we believe in
Christianity and yet whenever anyone
says that there is a caveat that says I
like Christianity I like the churches I
like the civilization the Christianity
produced but I just don't believe in the
thing that produced it I don't believe
in the thing that animated it and I
don't know I see this a lot on the left
I talk about this all the time lefties
want to drink decaf coffee you know they
want to get a university degree without
a university education they always want
the semblance of the thing the
appearance of the thing but not the
essence of the thing not the thing that
animates it and so I wonder to the
second point of
what you've talked about you say you
believe that the 10 commandments ought
to be the structure of civil the bedrock
of civilization the Christian foundation
there ought to be more churches for more
civic society civil society but why if
it isn't true if it if it if the Ten
Commandments don't come from God why
should why should they be the foundation
of society or on the flipside why have
they worked well I think that they have
objectively produced the best societies
in the whole history you know that and
and so you know even if you were to take
the religious aspect out of it you could
say that these values if you look at
these values from a from a you know non
religious perspective you could say
these values have produced these great
societies and on that merit you know
they should be but why have they
produced a great as deities because
they're congruous and good I'm not I'm
not sure I are they good idea I'm right
this is one argument for God right as
you keep you saying why is this better
than that why is this better than that
and eventually you get to the perfect
good so my only question is I think
people Bend themselves over backwards to
try to make Christianity secular on the
alright and I just don't not not only do
I now see if it's possible I don't see
why they would do it in the first place
yeah no I'm I don't really inherently
disagree with you I I think you're
probably correct about a lot of this
it's not something but here's the thing
it's not something that is I guess that
I spend a lot of time thinking about
perhaps I should think about it more I
don't and I don't by the way I don't
mean this in I don't mean to be
patronizing I know I sound like I'm
patronizing but I think there are a lot
of young conservatives that you
represent and that you can speak to and
that you're a voice for and I think that
on the road of thinking thoughtfully and
of reading a lot of books people come up
with some kooky ideas and go down bad
paths and people who are in the public
eye who go on camera have the misfortune
of knowing that the Internet is forever
and you're going to be chased by this
for the rest of your life and it it
might behoove people to think about the
conclusions the logical extremes of
their ideas before they make grand
statements and the reason we talk about
Christianity is it seems that the
religion the Christianity that created
the West the west of the alt-right
alleges to defend objects to a great
many things that the alt-right is
advocating and doing in particular the
racist aspect of it in particular
separating people categorically by race
advocating things like the ethnos state
so on and so forth it seems to me I mean
I think you would be bored if I read all
of the all of the scriptures about it
you probably take my word for it but
there are endless scriptures that talk
about this this fundamental
contradiction the alt-right seems to me
irreconcilable and shows the movement
for what it is which i think is
half-witted sort of like the New York
Times editorial board you know this
these guys who are a little bit smart
and so they convince the New York Times
readers to believe their idiocy but I
really think it's it's half-witted
you can respond so yeah sure so I guess
the question then you have to ask is
where the founding fathers wrong because
again going back to 1790 and and we're
saying that you know these people were
Christians I would have actually said
they're theists but if we want to say
they're Christians that's that's fine
thank you very many of them were
Christian I think some were deistic
there was some plurality but they all
came from the Puritan stock that came
over here on the Mayflower ya know yeah
exactly right
so then you look at the 1792
Naturalization Immigration Act and the
1790 Naturals or Immigration Act I
should say explicitly restricted
citizenship to free white people of good
character and that was a standard up
until the the mid to late 1800s and so I
guess we could then say you know where
the founder is wrong to say well I don't
like that generally you would surely you
would agree that history requires
context and that the Society of 2017
excuse me it's quite different than the
Society the late 18th century of course
yeah no of course
so therefore laws would change right
opinions would change even people would
change a people that have been held in
bondage for 200 years in the Americas or
who have come out of a civilization in
Africa that is in very few ways similar
to the civilization of the West
sure later their position might be a
little different in society and the laws
would reflect that after the slaves are
emancipated after Jim Crow is
obliterated and you know we arrived at
2017 in a basically equalitarian play
right and I'm not arguing that we should
you know return to this or anything I'm
just saying that this is this is the
situation and this is the system that
the founding fathers set up that these
Christian set up and throughout the vast
majority of the Christian history these
kind of policies were accepted and were
put in place and so it's actually a
relatively short time in the Christian
history that we've we believed in this
notion of a callous Arian seems to me
that slavery especially slavery's we're
talking about in the United States is an
aberration in the history of the West it
wasn't practiced it certainly not as it
was in the United States for all of the
West and and by the way that slavery
only came about because we interacted
with people for the first time in the
west coast of Africa in a in a trade
relationship well that's not entirely
true I mean the Europeans held plates
for many years slavery can trace its
roots back to you know the Islamic world
you know and uh the Islamic I'm not
denying that there was a Lavery in the
West the gorse had helots and the Romans
had slaves but those institutions of
slavery were quite different and they
they also were less racial depending on
depending on which errors in which
places we're talking about in history
the West sure and there were also quite
a bit more brutal and then so it's
important to remember that the American
form of slavery was actually and this is
I'm sure this will be cut out of context
somewhere but the American form of
slavery is actually one of the the
gentle ER forms of slavery that existed
you know the Egyptians would actually
you know do horrible things to their
slaves or castration etc before they
would ever take them as as into bondage
and so yeah you know history is history
is replete with brutality and horrible
things sure and parts of the American
experience of slavery different
different decades were different but
parts were quite brutal in other other
parts of relatively less perhaps today
than in the years right before the war I
suppose that's right you know one issue
because we've been kind of dancing
around the culture and race and it seems
to me that you know any any racial
categorical differences as they would
matter for Public Policy might just as
easily be explained by culture as by
genetics I know a lot of people on the
old rights say that race and culture are
inextricably linked would you agree with
that I don't think that's no I don't
think that's entirely true
I agree also I just see it flying around
quite a lot and I think that's another
example of some of the stupidities that
the allright is promulgating the other
is do we need to worry about the thing
that they can't stop talking about is
racial differences in IQ as posited by
charles murray is there is there any
implication for Public Policy by these
handfuls of studies that have shown some
correlation well I don't know if it's if
there's necessarily an implication for
Public Policy but I think it's an a it's
an important thing to understand because
it helps us understand why certain
groups tend to on average I'll be very
clear 10 - on average perform
differently than others in society you
look at why there are some of the Asians
for example to get into very top - your
schools why Asians do so well in the SAT
well it's it's due to the fact that
Asians tend to have an IQ closer to
around 110 you don't think it's
culturally over there because they
because those those cultural groups put
more of an emphasis on studying more of
an emphasis on schooling you know think
it's possibly explain well that what
scientists would argue is that it's a
mixture of both but what scientists
would argue I don't have any scientists
and I've only got you I'm kidding I I
drew well I tried to make crazy good
luck to you this is the thing lefties do
they would say well what I think
scientists would argue is I think I
don't know you don't know any scientists
I I'm not a scientist myself just a
gentleman right guys right yeah well go
ahead you're ready to split yeah no and
this is very well researched that many
of the people who research is kind of
think professionally argue that
intelligence is about 80% genetic and
about 20% cultural and and through the
the nurture it's a nature versus nurture
debate right and so while certain things
that are our cultural can influence your
ultimate intelligence you know if you if
you are you know born to you know brain
surgeon parents but you're raised in a
crack house you're probably not going to
be as smart as someone who is born to
more average parents who's raised it by
you know brain surgeons so yeah of
course no one's did not no one would
ever deny that cultural and and nurture
nurturing aspects can affect some with
ultimate intelligence but we can't
dismiss the genetic aspect of
intelligibly whether if sure so whether
that that is true or not you don't think
that there's any implication of that for
policy in the US no I I don't
necessarily think so yeah that's kind of
a debate question I think that we ought
to take into account the alleged racial
differences in IQ or categorical
differences in IQ when we make public
policy at the federal level or at the
local level I don't I don't think no I I
don't think I don't think we should
because I think it'd be unconstitutional
right I think there would be issues with
discrimination and and one of the the
failings of social science like this is
that it is not uniform right there are
bell curves and when you understand the
bell curve you understand that there are
you know a large population in the
middle but there are you know twelve and
a half percent of the population that's
on that upper echelon and you know
twelve and a percent that's on the lower
lashline and so there is certainly
crossover right there are thousands if
not millions of people who are you know
Hispanic and black in this country who
are smarter than Asian people that's and
that's of course that's true
you're only going to debate that do you
agree as I I think you're you're stating
well and absolutely I also think there
shouldn't be any any public policy drawn
from these social scientific studies but
do you agree with the deputy you know
the alright is such a vague term Hillary
Clinton gave me the name for my panel
the panel of deplorable z-- when she
lumped basically all right wingers in
with this this term it's been watered
down to nothing Milo innopolis said he
was in and then he isn't in it and then
yada yada yada some of the thought
leaders that people have seem to agree
on of the all right the mile up witness
piece for instance Richard Spencer Vox
day Jared Taylor people who came up with
the term who promote the term they've
given definitions of the alright that
are explicitly racial do you agree that
those are the definitions of the all
right or are Richard Spencer and all
those guys wrong I think that well I
haven't read their their definition so
I'm not going to latch on to one of them
specifically and agree to excite know
what what I think it green to I can tell
you what it is I'll read Vox days says
well he gives fourteen points which for
those who have been in the dregs of the
internet for a while know what the
implication of that is but Vox Dei says
the alt-right does not believe in
general supremacy of any race nation
people were subspecies interesting
choice of words through every
race Nation people and human subspecies
has its own strengths and weaknesses and
possesses the right to dwell unmolested
in the native culture perverse its
anti-equality rien it believes identity
leads culture which leads politics the
Richard Spencer says it's essentially
about racial identity he had that kind
of flashy creepy video on his old
version of alright calm which has
changed
Jared Spencer there Jared Spencer Jared
Taylor head of American Renaissance also
popularized the term Walt right says
that it's explicitly about turning from
conservatism to an alternative which is
where the alt comes from which is
essentially a white identity movement
would you agree with any of those or do
you think those guys get the alt-right
wrong well I think the you certainly I
don't know I'm not going to agree to any
of those I haven't really thought about
that to a level where I can agree to
that but what I will say is that I think
it's important to understand that that
race is a real concept we can't be we
can't be afraid of talking about race as
conservatives has have for so long but I
think the problem that conservatives
have a lot of conservatives I won't
speak for all of them is that they've
been so afraid to address differences in
in racial groups for the longest time
and it's led to this almost paralysis
whether whether too afraid to even
address the topic and this is an area
where where the left has you know the
left has identified the problem but they
haven't identified the right to live
identify the absolute wrong solution my
opinion you know that they've identified
that different racial groups tend to
have different interests and you know
that doesn't speak for every individual
of course but there tend to be different
interests for these different groups and
so they've they've been at they've been
able to exploit that for political gain
you think of the Obama coalition of the
ascendant for example is a fantastic
example of that and so but I what do you
what do you mean by different
interracial this because I do agree with
you conservatives are squeamish to talk
about race because anytime they talk
about taxes they get called a racist and
Coulter once told me that when a liberal
calls you a racist you know you've won
the argument but there there are
legitimate racists out there as well you
know my I don't want to be called a
racist by the left because I'm not a
racist it's not because I'm afraid of
the left or something like that so what
are those racial interests of those
groups what are you say we're afraid to
about race what should we be talking
about with regard to race so I'll give
you examples of those different
interests for example if you look at how
Hispanics tend to vote in this country a
Pew Research has done fantastic research
on all of this Hispanics will tend to
vote because they they come when you
think about this they come generally
from societies with large governments
they have a culture that that is are
they they bring over a tradition of
large government when they emigrate here
Hispanic immigrants will vote 70 to 34
they pull 70 to 30 for bigger governor
right when you ask them if they support
bigger or smaller government they say
bigger government what about my children
even my favorite people in the world
the Cubans who gave us excellent cigars
and music and fled that bum Fidel Castro
those guys wrote where they vote about a
hundred to zero Republican and they come
from the biggest government islands that
you could imagine doesn't that fly in
the face of those those numbers well and
you can always find an anecdote to
disprove attract I don't think a country
is an ESCO I think Cuba is a pretty
large number of people they swing
Florida sure and and they vote you know
60/40 for Republicans but when we're
talking about Hispanics broadly that's
not the trend that exists the trend as
research and I'm not I'm not making this
up you can look at your research ed who
is cited multiple times on the daily
wire you can look at P research and they
will corroborate this that Hispanics
tended to go 70 30 for bigger government
sure I don't deny it but anything's to
me what you're talking about now is
culture rather than race perhaps I'm
misunderstanding what you're saying but
it seems to me that race is a biological
construct and that culture is a culture
cultural construct a social construct is
that wrong so if it we're talking about
big government people coming from
different areas in both 70/30 or 60/40
or whatever that seems to me not
biological are you are you suggesting
that we need to talk about biological
implications of different peoples or
just cultural ones no look I look I
don't want to get into those semantics
of that all I'm telling you is that
these are how you know these different
immigrant groups vote but I'm not I
don't know by the way people should
remember that semantics means meaning so
when people say well that's just
semantics they mean to say it's just
trivial but it is a meaningful
distinction that's the main distinction
I'm asking about or are you only talking
about culture or are you too
talking about rates because everything
you've said is cultural and I agree we
need to teach people from other cultures
to vote for Republicans I think that
should be priority number one but are we
close the borders and stop them from
immigrating sure there are plenty of the
good arguments for lower immigration for
building the wall absolutely but are
there any arguments explicitly about
race about the physical aspect the
biological aspect are you just talking
cultural well Michael I don't know why
they vote the way they do I don't know
why the way way why they vote for bigger
government you think there might be a
biological aspect to it no you not only
think so I haven't seen I haven't seen
your research no I don't know look I
don't know um I don't I'm willing to bet
I'd bet my four hundred buckaroo Bureau
that there is no biological impetus to
to vote for Republican other than maybe
a little more testosterone now who knows
who knows do you already had that that's
interesting they have a budget on that
yes wait so all right I think we've gone
over this I've grilled you enough do you
review you've you've been taken around
on this whole thing you had to step down
I think as the head of the Washington
State Republicans is that right
I was not forced to do anything I
immediately planning on doing that for
weeks before yeah no I I wanted to get
let them start the year fresh we're
starting school in a week I wanted to
let them start without with
distraction-free do you do you regret
going to the event I've even hammered
about this I think you've been rightly
hammered about this but I give a little
grace to you because I understand that
ideas can lead to ideas and some of
these guys are somewhat articulate and
it's easy to think the wrong things
sometimes
do you regret going to wish you hadn't
done it no not at all I think that it's
important to provide media coverage of
events like this that is going to be
representative of the actual event when
you look at the reports that came out
from places like the New York Times or
CNN or Fox News they were latching onto
that one or two pictures of the guy with
the swastika flag and saying this is
what the event is this is this is all
these things all of the organizers were
white identity advocates you'll grant
that I'm not saying they're all Hitler
Youth I'm saying they all were
advocating white identity there were in
organizers who came from any other
branch of the right you will at least
grant them that premise I don't think
that's actually that's not actually true
there were the other ones ictus you were
there people like Augustus Invictus
like Christopher Cantwell these people
are are libertarians you know these
people come from the libertarian Estes
invictus is a former and current
candidate for libertarian libertarian or
for the Senate as a libertarian in
Florida right this there was a wide
swath of people from the right wing
invited there but I would also have to
put well there were a lot of were
invited I grant you there were a lot who
were invited but even people who have
played around with you all right like
Gavin Gavin McGinnis said no thank you I
don't want a part of it but earlier on
you had granted to me that a major a
foundational part of this march in this
rally was white identity
do you now disagree with that no no I
don't push back on that at all and I
think that but I disagree with the
inherent assertion that that's a bad
thing right because again we see these
people all across the country organizing
for black interests organizing for black
identity for Hispanic identity for Asian
American identity but we don't see
anything wrong we criticize them for
doing that don't we maybe you do but I
don't you don't all right maybe you can
I look I don't see anything wrong with
with finding a common cause with a
community like that you think that race
has won outright using race as a
category is a primary and important
political grouping do you think it's
worth worth bringing more racial
identity politics to the fore in America
I don't well that's speaking of some
kind of grand strategy context I don't
know about about all that but I do know
that that you know race is very
important for a lot of people in this
country for it's very important for a
lot of black people very important for a
lot of Hispanics for a lot of Asians and
it historically really hasn't been that
important for white people but I think
that is changing at all of these anti
white attacks these anti white
narratives going on in the media and
government it's causing people to become
conscious of their status as a white
person which is then leading them toward
things like the all right I I agree
there has been a backlash the left the
left started the fight on racial
identity politics I think it's a very
bad thing and ought to be opposed or
perhaps you disagree with me on that but
nevertheless before we go we've we've
taught you what ideal Society I'd agree
with you I I would agree with that ideal
right I would absolutely
love for us to be able to drop at any
politics and talk about you know the
benefits of laissez-faire capitalism and
the free market that will be fantastic
but unfortunately what we're seeing is
that these people on the Left are not
going to take their foot off the gas now
they're going to keep attacking white
people keep blaming white people keep
demonizing white people in this country
as the sources root of all evil and I
think that's I think that's silly and I
think unfortunately that's going to lead
to to more and more of this type of
stratification so I would love for us to
be able to go back you know six years or
whatever and talk about you know the
intricacies of healthcare policy or
something but that's really not what's
what is being pushed by the left we're
not even talking I don't think anybody
ever wants to talk about the intricacies
of healthcare policy or tax taxes
insurance or whatever I it's very boring
it's always been a cultural battle there
have always been cultural warriors and
their end the primary motivator of that
cultural war especially on the right has
historically been the primary animator
of the Western civilization that we say
that we're going to offend Christianity
it seems to me now that that is being
substituted for white race and I think
you would probably grant me that do you
think that's a good thing
do you think that's a necessary thing do
you think that that's something we
should oppose for both practical and
moral reasons as I do
well I think that I don't think they are
necessarily different I think that when
you look into I'm going to read your
Bible James I think I'm going to send
you all those well hold on hold that I
compiled I would appreciate that yeah
but but I think when you see people
arguing for a lot of stuff they're
arguing for Christian civilization right
they're arguing for a continuance of
Western Christians they just don't
practice oceanic and so but they do want
Christian civilization I agree with you
I'm someone do this is quite imagine ooh
like like I I haven't taken a poll I
didn't take a poll on everyone was it
unites the right on what their faith is
I would be willing to bet though that
the majority of them are probably
Christians I well we'd have to define
our terms but I would happily bet you my
Shapiro check on that we'll have we'll
have to say we'll have to see about that
I'm James it has been very nice having
you thank you for coming on I appreciate
it and and we will we'll talk to you
again in the future I'm sure right thank
you very much I appreciate it thank you
all right
that was a long one we've got to
introduce our panel of deplorable z--
now we have this is a brand new panel of
deplorable z-- we have thank goodness
Amanda presto Giacomo we she is flanked
by Joshy asthma and Aran Bandler both of
the daily wire guys started to keep you
so long usually we have a Funko FFA show
we had to talk about serious things oh
we re we also have to say goodbye to
facebooking because that because James
and I kept yapping for so so long so
thank you so much for everyone who is a
subscriber if you're a subscriber right
now go over to daily wire.com and you'll
be able to watch the rest
finally this panel of deplorable x' and
if you're not a subscriber but subscribe
what are you waiting for
go over now daily wire.com you'll get
may you'll get the intro flavin show you
get the Ben Shapiro show and the leftist
tears tumblr you can keep your leftist
here's hot or cold always salty and
delicious go there right now daily wire
calm
all right we don't have to talk about
this Charlotte's whole thing anymore do
we we've talked about it so much let's
get rid of it we have to move on to much
more important news than the neo-nazis
attacks in the United States we have to
talk about Donald Trump's tweeting
Donald Trump's wonderful tweeting Kim
jong-un has backed away from a
threatened missile strike on Guam which
President Trump hailed as a very wise
and well reasoned decision the
alternative would have been both
catastrophic and unacceptable with an
exclamation point in true trumpian
fashion Josh you're a foreign policy guy
president Trump has received a lot of
criticism for his comments in the
lead-up to this the fire and fury the
world has never seen anything like this
but did they work seems like they worked
well can I just say that I don't think
it's a good idea to be so cavalier about
tweeting national security and foreign
policy concerns why it seems to have
worked well the Trump hate it looks like
they're not going to buy Wow well what
hasn't been covered is the fact that we
have been negotiating with the North
Koreans throw back doored diplomatic
Channel sure US envoy for North Korea
Joseph UN he's been talking to his North
Korean counterpart and they've been kind
of negotiating some sort of truce or at
least a temporary so that hasn't been
covered ah that's much less interesting
in the tweets I bring the back channels
to Kim Jong woman yeah Amanda what do
you think between her I think there was
a lot of media hysteria over it this
language is actually not unprecedented
we saw Bill Clinton Barack Obama say
similar thanks not on Twitter but they
did a similar thing so it wasn't as you
know insane as people were making it out
to be I don't think it hurt anything
with North Korea I don't think they were
going to do anything in Guam anyhow they
know the United States kind of literates
them I think that was just you know
condone doing what he does flexing his
muscles he just doesn't want I don't
think he has a lot of muscle oh my god
oh yeah this is Joey
I don't I said that's like a week and a
half ago but I didn't think they were
going to clearly aren't going to do
anything and we're working the
diplomatic way but what Trump says on
Twitter I just don't think I had that
big of an effect I don't think it hurt
us but it wasn't as Extreme as the media
made that to me did Trump win here
despite himself himself Aaron well I
think that he actually did not help
themselves because I think that tough
language does help when it comes to
dealing with the roll maniacs like Kim
jong-un you know because the biggest
deterrent is strength no peace -
strength is Reagan always said and so I
think that I think that had Trump like
not fall through on that threat had
North Korea actually like attack mom so
that's been it would have been bad but
because he didn't have to and North
Koreans backed off it was okay she
talked to us and Kim Jeong goes back
down and sort of like a phantom it looks
like a Trump win yeah it doesn't light
assembly in that regard yeah I love
seeing the future like how that will
play out with other Rose regimes like
Iran and Syria and so forth but for now
it seems like a win yeah but there's
this trouble that now so we were all
looking forward we're going to blast
this guy off the police to the earth was
going to be a catastrophe up because
probably Seoul would have been destroyed
right but now we've saved Seoul we save
Guam we've saved Los Angeles in my
little studio but Kim is still in power
so are we just kicking the can down the
road Josh do we is there any hope for
regime change
well it's interesting invention that
general mattis and Secretary of State
killer Sun actually penned an op-ed in
the Wall Street Journal explicitly
saying that there will be no regime
change they wanted to make that clear so
I think the Kim regime has to be dealt
with but it's not a good idea to deal
with it right now we have to deal with
our immediate national security concerns
and making sure that our partners in the
Pacific are taken care of and that
includes promoting missile defense in
the region that includes making sure
that our bases have the resources and
the money they need to function properly
but you know this has been the argument
since the 90s right bill Bill Clinton is
the first president to deal
real crisis in North Korea and luckily
for him Kim il-sung dies and there are
their famines and he gets to kick the
can down the road president bush
obviously is dealing with other wars
meanwhile North Korea shoots off
missiles is mustn't this be dealt with
at some point
well Trump has been doing a good job at
pressuring China and I think that's the
key might this whole thing in the weeks
leading up to the unprecedented UN
sanctions on on North Korea which you
know sanctions to a billion dollars
worth of exports coal you know North
Korea's primary exports primarily to
China China didn't veto that that
resolution which is huge and the reason
they didn't veto that is because the
Trump administration pressured China and
said if you veto that bill we are going
to place sanctions on Chinese banks
Chinese banks that may or may not be
doing business with North Korea so the
Chinese were scared in the back down
that's the key to this whole thing we
have to work with the the framework in
the reason we have to work with partners
in the region to pressure North Korea I
mean simply striking them that's not
going to get anywhere you know Kim is
still going to be in power and it's
going to lead to you know this standoff
so you're you're advocating the art of
the deal you're proponents OMI we make
the best deals don't we folks all right
enough of that Kim we have to talk about
speaking of cartoonish evil we have to
talk about Iceland committing a genocide
against down-syndrome people this is
from I think CBS well with the rise of
prenatal screening tests across Europe
in the United States the number of
babies born with Down syndrome has
significantly decreased but few
countries have come as close to
eradicating Down syndrome births as
Iceland eradicating Down syndrome birth
amanda has there ever been a more absurd
euphemism for killing a lot of people
everything about abortion is cloaked in
euphemism and this is particularly
disgusting because they're framing this
is a moral good that we're eradicating
Down syndrome no you murdered all the
preborn babies who had Down syndrome
that's not a scientific advancement
that's that it didn't cure it right all
right this is
I mean it's interesting too because we
just had this discuss I'm not excusing
this is disgusting all these neo-nazis
in Charles ville vile stuff okay
you want to talk about Nazism what about
this I mean we're not going to say
anything about eliminating human beings
that you deem unworthy of life do
eugenic organizing yeah I'm gonna kill
the immigration so we have the same
extreme outrage over this as we did for
those 200 losers who of course there's a
disgusting murder I'm not again I'm not
downplaying that but where is the
outrage over this and again this is
happening in America too this is not
just some foreign thing that's going on
it's happened right in the United States
every day of course and you know that
the left all the time they make these
quality of life arguments that when
they're talking about euthanasia or
they're talking about a boring mentally
[ __ ] babies and syndrome why is
there any argument for quality of life
do their arguments hold any sway or is
it just sophistry it's just I mean how
to work who are they to say about what
the best quality of life of somebody is
I think the first press aside that is
the person themselves or their family
members and so forth not for them to say
I'm actually discussing to say that
somebody can't live about that is
because they have like Down syndrome or
like your ability or something and is
that it's your point in the United
States I think by six percent of
abortions are done because because of
they found out they have those
conditions like you're uploading it now
syndrome and so forth and it's
disgusting and it's very reminiscent oh
the next movement
I leave the newly 1920s over which Marx
is saying you're the founder Planned
Parenthood was a big supporter of and so
forth I mean it really is evil it's like
not to give them basically it's
disgusting well with the advance with
the advance of these public policies and
then with the advance of designer babies
we're seeing new stories about that
every day will we eventually eliminate
Down syndrome people will we not see
anymore Down syndrome people so I think
we have to draw a distinction between
the abortion element and genetic
engineering I don't think there's
anything morally wrong with gene therapy
with correcting these these issues that
you know that are going to put pressure
on families I mean we can't discount the
financial costs the emotional cost all
these things I mean there is something
to be said about these stressors
involved with having children with the
genetic disorders so like Down syndrome
would it be preferable if we could
correct it in the womb or would it not
be preferable um or does it depend on
the family some families want to get get
rid of their kid and some well I think
fundamentally parents have the right to
know so I think arguments that are
suggesting that both parents know you
know they'll get rid of the baby that's
100 percent they have a right to have a
prenatal screening or something yes 100
percent they need to know what they're
getting into and then you know the rest
of discussions of public policy
discussion you know I don't know about
you but we've been talking about a story
right now that isn't a tweet for far too
long so I think we have to go back at
weed
President Obama has now the most liked
tweet in the history of tweeting this
came in the wake of the terror attack in
Charlottesville he quoted no one is born
hating another person because of the
color of his skin or his background or
his religion and I think at the Nelson
Mandela quote isn't it the so Amanda is
this because it's a poignant message or
god help us is there nostalgia for
Barack Obama perhaps there is nostalgia
for Barack Obama I I don't see why I
mean it's interesting that he's the one
coming out and saying this under his
administration we thought endless
identity politics he helped bolster and
legitimize the black lives matter
movement invited them to the White House
all of this racial division was in Park
helped by President Barack Obama and his
administration and now we're seeing with
nasty reactionary stuff this is all of
course not 100% on President Obama but
it's just interesting to see that he
pushes this identity politic you know
this implicit bias right that we all
apparently have but then he quotes he
tweets that so which is it
am i inherently bias and racist because
I'm white or am I not or my taught that
so it contradicts his message and it's
just interesting that he helps promote
this backlash and this and you know
racism on the left and now he's coming
to save everyone it's just it's very
interesting and it does raise a question
which is is that quote
is it true that no one is born that way
is it that we only learn hatred or is it
the case that we're all born sort of
brutish and we need to have a civilized
out of us Josh what do you think so we
need to parse that out first of all what
Porsche anything you don't tell me what
the powers on my show I'm go ahead you
know
he's equating religion and race and
ethnicity which is you know
fundamentally that doesn't make sense
and that's what both we all right and
the far left there racializing islam
duty Gration it raping um I think that
religion has to be understood for what
it is it's an idea it's an idea that's
taught it's either true or untrue and
neither beneficial or right or
destructive under percent and you know
color of your skin you you're born white
or you're born black or you're born
brown some of us are born white but
because we're Sicilian we lay out in the
Sun and then we took just like Amanda
and I turn to the color of this brick
wall you're glowing but I'm going to
glow that there is the exception right
right so religion is taught race is not
taught but ideas associated with race
are taught um but I think that there is
there's something fundamentally
simplistic about what he's saying
because I think human beings are
predisposed to being attracted to people
that look like them I think there's a
reason that I'm not sure about that you
and I have a similar skin tone and I'm
in no way attracted to you we'd have to
move on folks yesterday some idiot to
face the Lincoln Memorial with the words
F law and the left on Twitter thought it
said F Islam I don't know where they got
that from but you know it does strike me
right now is that everybody hates
Abraham Lincoln everybody is it that
right is attacking Abraham Lincoln the
far left is attacking a rambling these
anarchists are attacking him Aaron what
is the deal why are people being so mean
hey babe please waking alone I think
that it's what works like I said there's
a lot more yosef everett Koop that's
always hated Lincoln now they're kind of
coming out above what works now with
though with the rise yacht right so
forth I think with the far left and the
anarchist I think I just want ter I
think but all those which have a comment
they want to tear everything down and
lick has always been associated as like
so like the one review guy that
everybody likes so it's almost like we
sure
areas to like you know say he's awful
stuff and obviously he's not making
Frieza slave that's awesome
and so he's always like number one or
number two a lot of like residential
listeners of libraries ranked and it's
really yes I forget Obama would make
himself number but it's not make himself
number one too probably
but so but that's my wife why say
there's so much hate towards them right
now that's interesting and that might
well be the case
Amanda any thoughts yeah no I don't
think I kind of agree with aarón I don't
think the Republic Republicans want
ownership of President Lincoln I don't
think there's hate because I don't I
don't associate Republicans with you
alright I think that's a different sex
so I don't think Republicans are
distancing themselves from Abraham
Lincoln I see it on the far left is
there anything and from be alright
sure all right speaking of the all right
well I've got to say goodbye to my panel
of deplorable we're not going to do a
final thought today I'll just give a
final sentence it seems to me that there
are four people like my guest James
Allsop and for other people who are
being attracted to some of these
alrighty ideas these alrighty
personalities online it seems subversive
they seem quasi articulate quasi
intelligent and it's a it seems fun with
all the memes and everything I would
just say look past the surface if you
scratch these guys below the skin you
are not going to find any substance
whatsoever
they say they defend Western
civilization they don't know a thing
about Western culture they don't they
don't practice this thing that animates
Western culture and if you like the rest
of us do want to defend Western culture
and do want to advance it then read a
book man read something about it learn
about your own culture and practice the
thing that made it so important those
values that we see embodied in our
United States Constitution and on that I
will see you all tomorrow I'm Michael
Knowles is the Michael Nolt show come
back tomorrow we'll do it again
[Music]